>>> WE'RE DAYS AWAY FROM THE
RELEASE OF THE JANUARY 6th
REPORT.
SOMETHING MONTHS IN THE MAKING
FROM THAT COMMITTEE.
AND AS WE ARE JUST DAYS AWAY
FROM IT WE ARE GETTING A
FAREWELL SPEECH FROM ONE OF THE
TWO REPUBLICANS ON THAT
COMMITTEE.
ADAM KINZINGER, WHO DURING A
FAREWELL SPEECH YESTERDAY WAS
TALKING ABOUT HIS LEAVE FROM
CONGRESS, WRAPPING UP THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK AND WHAT HE
BELIEVES IS A REFLECTION OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> THE ONCE GREAT PARTY OF
LINCOLN, ROOSEVELT AND REAGAN,
HAS TURNED ITS BACK ON THE
IDEALS OF LIBERTY AND
SELF-GOVERNANCE.
INSTEAD IT HAS EMBRACED LIES AND
DECEIT.
WE SHELTER THE IGNORANT, RACIST,
WHO ONLY STOKE ANGER AND HATRED
TO THOSE WHO ARE DIFFERENT THAN
US.
>> JOINING US IS CHIEF POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT DANA BASH.
DANA, IT'S REMARKABLE.
THIS ISN'T ANYTHING NEW FOR ADAM
KINZINGER HE'S BEEN CRITICAL OF
HIS OWN PARTY, ESPECIALLY WITH
TRUMP IN OFFICE AND JANUARY 6th.
BUT THAT -- HE'S CHOOSING TO
MAKE THAT HIS FAREWELL SPEECH ON
THE FLOOR FOR A REASON.
>> YES.
HE IS INCREDIBLY FRUSTRATED,
INCREDIBLY SAD.
I'LL GIVE YOU A LITTLE -- DON'T
TELL ANYBODY I'LL GIVE YOU A
PREVIEW.
I TALKED TO HIM FOR OUR JANUARY
1ST NEW YEAR'S DAY SHOW ON STATE
OF THE UNION AND HE GETS
EMOTIONAL.
HE IS EMOTIONAL.
HE FEELS VERY ABANDONED BY THE
PEOPLE IN HIS PARTY, BY HIS
COLLEAGUES WHO DID NOT STAND UP
TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT, DID NOT
STAND UP TO THE PEOPLE WHO HE
SERVES WITH STILL EVERY SINGLE
DAY, WHEN THEY DIDN'T ACT AND
REACT THE WAY HE EXPENCTED THEM
TO AFTER THEY WERE ATTACKED BY
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE -- WHO WERE
STOKED AND PEOPLE WHO WERE
FOLLOWING THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
AND IT JUST IS SO TELLING.
YOU ALL REMEMBER IT WASN'T THAT
LONG AGO HE WAS THE DARLING OF
THE GOP.
PERFECT RESUME, ABLE TO TALK ON
TV, A MILITARY GUY, HE'S STILL
IN THE RESERVES.
AND LOOK AT WHERE HE IS TODAY.
HE DECIDED TO RETIRE, BECAUSE HE
WAS GOING TO LOSE A PRIMARY.
>> SO -- I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THE
INTERVIEW.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
YOU -- SOMETHING ELSE THAT
YOU'RE DOING.
YOU INTERVIEWED CHRIS SUNUNU FOR
YOUR SPECIAL.
IS IT CALLED "BEING SUNUNU".
>> BEING CHRIS SUNUNU.
>> WATCH THIS.
>> THAT'S WHY WHEN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED HE'S RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT A WEEK AFTER THE
ELECTION, EVERYONE WENT OKAY.
HE'S ANNOUNCING HE'S RUNNING AT
HIS MOST POLITICALLY WEAK POINT.
HE'S DOING IT FROM A POINT OF
WEAKNESS FROM WHATEVER HIS
AGENDA IS.
IT'S A BLIP ON THE RADAR.
THERE'S AN ARGUMENT TO BE MADE
HE'S NOT EVEN A FRONT RUNNER.
>> SUNUNU ALWAYS HAD A UNIQUE
RELATIONSHIP WITH TRUMP,
CRITICAL AT TIMES.
>> WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT SPEAKS
IN HYPERBOLE TWEETS AND ALL
THAT.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TO CAMPAIGN WITH YOU?
>> I DON'T NEED ANYONE TO
CAMPAIGN WITH ME.
>> HE DOESN'T DEFINE CHRIS
SUNUNU OR EVEN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
>> BUT HE ESCAPED TRUMP'S
COUNTER PUNCH.
>> YOU MANAGED TO WALK THIS LINE
THAT MOST REPUBLICANS HAVE NOT.
HOW?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, EARLY ON,
WHEN HE BECAME PRESIDENT, WE
MADE IT REALLY CLEAR, BOTH WITH
HIM, WE HAD A RELATIONSHIP, AND
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE, LOOK WHEN
HE DOES THINGS WITH POLICY -- IF
HE DOES THINGS THAT DESERVE
CREDIT I'LL BE THE FIRST ONE TO
STAND UP AND GIVE CREDIT.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A TONE OR
SOMETHING I DISAGREE WITH, I'M
GOING TO SAY THAT TOO.
>> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE HE'S
SAYING THAT, BUT HE'S ALSO
TOUTING RON DeSANTIS AS A
STRONGER CANDIDATE THAN DONALD
TRUMP.
>> HE SAID THAT TO ME
UNPROMPTED, GUYS, WHEN WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE 2024 FIELD.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, I DID ASK
ABOUT HIS PLAN, YOU HAVE TO TUNE
IN TONIGHT TO SEE WHAT HE SAID
ABOUT THAT --
>> YOU WON'T TELL US, DANA, COME
ON.
>> WE WERE TALKING MORE BROADLY
ABOUT THE FIELD.
HE SAID, YOU KNOW, AS YOU HEARD,
DONALD TRUMP ISN'T NECESSARILY
EVEN THE FRONT RUNNER.
AND THAT HE SHOULDN'T BE
PRESIDENT AGAIN.
BECAUSE THE COUNTRY HAS RIGHTLY
MOVED ON FROM HIM.
IT WAS VERY, VERY -- PRETTY
HARSH WHEN IT COMES TO DONALD
TRUMP.
BUT WE ALSO -- THE WHOLE GOAL OF
THIS SERIES IS TO SPEND TIME
WITH THE PEOPLE IN THE NEWS, THE
PEOPLE WHO YOU COVER ON YOUR
SHOW AND HAVE INTERVIEWS WITH
LIKE YOU DO WITH CHRIS SUNUNU.
AND SPENT QUALITY TIME WITH HIM
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
I'LL TELL YOU THERE WAS SOME
GETTING ON A LADDER, NOT ME,
HIM, PUTTING SOME HOMEMADE
DECORATIONS, HALLOWEEN
DECORATIONS ON HIS HOUSE.
HE HAS A VINTAGE 1966 RED
MUSTANG.
AND WE MAY HAVE GOTTEN IN IT TO
GO BUY A PUMPKIN.
>> THAT'S QUITE A TEASE IF I'VE
EVER HEARD ONE.
>> IT'S FASCINATING WHAT WHAT
HAD SAID ABOUT DeSANTIS,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE CNN POLLS WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT YESTERDAY HOW
REPUBLICANS DON'T THINK TRUMP
SHOULD BE THE NOMINEE AND THEY
LIKE DeSANTIS AS THEIR SECOND
BEST BET: T.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
BEFORE THE ELECTION HE PREDICTED
TO ME THAT THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE FOR SENATE, DON BOLDUC
WOULD WIN, HE LOST BY NINE
POINTS.
AFTERWARDS HE ADMITTED, I WAS
WRONG.
IT WAS SO TELLING THAT HE WAS SO
CONFIDENT THAT HE KNEW HIS
STATE, KNEW WHERE THE TRENDS
WERE, AND THE FACT THAT HE SO
MISJUDGED HOW REPUBLICANS WOULD
DO IN HIS OWN STATE IS VERY
TELLING ABOUT HOW REPUBLICANS
NATIONWIDE MISJUDGED WHERE
THINGS ARE.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF SOUL
SEARCHING RIGHT NOW.
HE IS ONE OF THE PEOPLE DOING
THAT AND TRYING TO HELP FIGURE
OUT WHERE THE PARTY SHOULD GO.
>> CAN'T WAIT TO WATCH THAT.
DANA BASH, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANKS, DB.
SEE YOU.